General Motors announced an ambitious
proposal overnight to remove steering
wheels in self-driving cars the
automaker wants to build vehicles with
open dashboards like this cruise
autonomous vehicle Kris Van Cleave in
Washington shows us why GM has to
overcome both legal obstacles and driver
expectations with this concept Kris good
morning well good morning GM hopes to
start testing those vehicles with no
internal controls here soon and the
Department of Transportation just this
week announced it was going to start the
process of creating the rules for
vehicles say without a steering wheel
but the idea of getting rid of the
steering wheel has some drivers wanting
to pump the brakes something is missing
from this car and it's a sneak peek of
what the future may look like a
self-driving smart car without a
steering wheel or even a brake pedal
General Motors says it's ready to start
building them now it's pretty buzz
worthy at low from Motor Trend when you
start taking away fundamental controls
like the gas pedal the brakes and the
steering wheel it does really make the
prospect of autonomous driving all the
more real to get this self-driving car
on the road by 2019 GM announced this
morning it's filed a petition with the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration asking the government to
waive some federal standards pertaining
to human driven cars self-driving cars
and even this self-flying volocopter
were big players at this year's Consumer
Electronics Show electric car maker
Buyten sees the car of the future as a
mobile lounge a bit of a movie theater
on wheels but a new survey out this
morning by the advocates for highway and
auto safety found Americans may not be
quite ready to let go of the wheel
advocates president Cathy chase we
frankly were surprised with how
concerned the American public is 64%
expressed concern about sharing the
roads with driverless cars and a full 75
percent are not comfortable with
disconnecting vehicle equipment like
that steering wheel what do you think it
is about the concern the reticence
people seem to have about the steering
wheel going away they've had it the
entire history of the of the car so
taking away such an essential component
of a car is a seismic shift
and assuming Jim can get the approval
from the federal government the company
believes at least seven states will
allow it to test the cars with no
steering wheel Jim plans to work with
other states that have laws on the books
like you have to have one hand on the
wheel if there's no wheel you probably
don't need that law Nora no a good boy
Chris yeah I love his question what is
the reticence of taking away the
steering wheel it steers the car I'm
trying to get used to a self-driving car
I know just let me have a steering wheel
it's interesting yeah it's a new world
yeah it is I'm excited about it sorry
about it